feuer mit kerosin bekämpfen eine
verdammt schlechte idee kritiker der
italienischen regierung werfen ihr aber
gerade das vor einem gewaltigen
schuldenberg des landes mit neuen
schulden anzuhäufen den haushaltsplan
der regierung in rom hat die eu
kommission die für die stabilität in
europa verantwortlich ist rundheraus
verworfen
ein einmaliger vorgang streit mit
italien droht die nächste euro-krise das
thema heute in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde ja herzlich willkommen bei
uns liebe zuschauer meine gäste im
studio flaminio resort ist bei uns von
der italienischen tageszeitung il
messaggero und die erscheint in rom
professor sinn ist langjähriger
präsident des ifo instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung
mein kollege wolf dieter krause
langjähriger leiter des ard-studios
inklusive und professor alexander
kritikos forschungsdirektor am deutschen
institut für wirtschaftsforschung die
idee frottee ist italien das ja immerhin
ein gründungsmitglied ist
damals hieß das noch europäische
wirtschaftsgemeinschaft und
gründungsmitglied europas ist italien zu
einer art anti europa festung geworden
wir bekommen ganz unterschiedliche im
forst in den in der in der frage zum
beispiel man sieht einerseits dass die
beliebtheitswerte von premierminister
von den zwei vize sehr hoch sind
gleichzeitig und man würde sagen die
machen eine anti europäische politik
gleichzeitig 62 prozent der italiener
sind gegen einen austritt aus dem euro
und aus der europäische union das heißt
das ist glaube ich auch ein bisschen der
beweis dafür in welcher wieder
sportliche situation in europa nicht so
sehr sie wissen was sie an europa haben
und deswegen sind sie eigentlich eher
dafür dass alles so bleibt wie es ist
auch wenn es sehr viele diskussionen
gibt es in deutschland und frankreich
haben das ja vor jahren vorgemacht wie
man auf die maastricht kriterien also
diese europäischen notierend für die
währungsstabilität so richtig pfeifen
kann ohne dass irgendwelche konsequenzen
gibt es ist ein wunder dass italien da
eine art nachahmer effekt jetzt zeigt ja
man kann das verstehen im lichte dieser
vertragsverletzung damals ich weiß noch
genau wie also kollegen ältere kollegen
von mir gesagt haben diese ganzen
kriterien werden nur eingehalten wenn
deutschland sich als erstes einmal
bestrafen lässt aber deutschland wollte
sich nicht bestrafen lassen und
da kam es zur verletzung man muss aber
sehen inzwischen haben wir ja ein
anderes szenario um das war ja in der
zeit vor der krise jetzt in der krise
hatte es im jahr 2012 den gehärteten
fiskal packt gegeben wonach die
schuldenquoten eines jeden landes
sukzessive pro jahr in richtung auf 60
prozent fallen sollten um ein
zwanzigstel des abstandes und das war
verlangt worden weil gleichzeitig die
noch stabilen länder deutschland allen
voran mit ihren schutz den gläubigern
der krisenländer südeuropas gegeben
haben und sie in die lage versetzt haben
sich zu niedrigen zinsen zu verschulden
und da hieß es dann von deutscher seite
wenn wir euch helfen zu niedrigen zinsen
euch zu verschulden weil wir im zweifel
gerade stehen gegenüber den den
gläubigern
dann müsst ihr versprechen dass sie das
nicht ausnutzt indem er jetzt euro
schulden reduziert aber das ist eben
nicht passiert ist der conti-kurs das
ist ja dieser konflikt italien gegen eu
das ist ja ein konflikt mit ansage
die herren matteo salvini der
innenminister von lega nord und luigi di
maio der chefs der fünf sterne bewegung
aus die beiden koalitionspartner in rom
die sind ja vor allen dingen wie es
scheint anderer dauer interessiert ist
diese persönliche ebene eigentlich viel
gefährlicher als die ökonomische sie
kann dann gefährlicher werden wenn in
diesen jetzt anstehenden verhandlungen
die 1 2 millionen kommen von die
italienische seite einfach überhaupt
keine kompromissbereitschaft zu tage
treten sollte
was wir bisher gesehen haben
signalisieren sie zumindest
positionen diese richtung wir wollen
jetzt dass es endlich mal durchziehen
dass wir unsere position wir wollen
diese schulden machen dass wir diese
position gegenüber dem wenn wir es mal
feind europa so bezeichnen dieses jahr
gerne dass wir uns durchsetzen und für
unser volk etwas tun
insofern ist diese persönliche ebene
tatsächlich gefährlich wenn wir so ein
bisschen in die jüngere vergangenheit
schauen hat sich auch gezeigt durch den
austausch einer person kann sich ja ganz
schön auch etwas ändern
insofern fürchte ich derzeit das
tatsächlich wie auf absehbare zeit also
für den weiteren verlauf dieses jahres
wirklich einen konfrontativen kurs von
italien sehen werden da bleibt dann
immer die frage offen wie lange tragen
sie ist wenn die markt entsprechend
negativ reagieren
krause wie es viele solcher politischer
materialschlachten wie jetzt mit italien
kann sich denn die europäische union
noch leisten eigentlich gar keine bin
ich sie aber vorher noch mal kurz
korrigieren da wird es zeit in
deutschland gerne wird gerne gesagt dass
deutschland die verträge gebrochen habe
seinerzeit unter unterstreiche das
stimmt nicht den vertrag hat man damals
eingehalten der erlaubte auch unter
bestimmten bedingungen mehr als drei
prozent defizit zu machen
und damals hat man im ministerrat eine
sperrminorität gehabt damit wohl das
defizit verfahren gestoppt das war
politisch 2 mg fand einen ein grandioser
fehler katastrophaler fehler aber der
vertrag wo du nicht gebrochen
das ist heute anders wir haben sehr
windigen zusagen gegenüber frankreich
gehabt
in frankreich hat in 17 jahren euro das
erlaubte defizit viermal eingehalten und
die kommission hat immer wieder
frankreich verlängerung gegeben und in
weit kann die kommission jetzt deswegen
auch gegenüber italien nicht so gut
argumentieren da jetzt plötzlich hart zu
sein
ein junge hat gesagt wenn frankreich
frankreich ist gehen wir so mit
frankreich um ja und das ist weil in
italien italien ist
wer also vor dem recht müssen alle
gleich seien die großen und die kleinen
und und und da diese kommission wie ich
finde in den letzten jahren auch
unglaublichen schaden angerichtet aber
wir sehen doch dass dieses ganze projekt
europa uns im moment und ist doch schon
längst dabei uns unter den händen zu
zerbröseln
weil das das projekt europa basiert auf
vereinbarung alle friedliche politik
führt zu vereinbaren
gesetze sind das ergebnis von
vereinbarungen koalitionsvertrag alles
möglich wenn die nicht mehr gelten dann
ist politik eigentlich an ihrem ende
und vor dieser situation stehen wir in
europa inzwischen in einer dramatischen
weise weil das nicht nur in der sache
schlimm ist sondern weil es gleichzeitig
auch die bürger enttäuscht
die dann von diesem sagen dieses europa
kann mir gestohlen bleiben die das in
außenpolitik nichts hinkriegen dass
versprechungen macht dies nicht mehr
hält und die wählen dann auch noch
solche parteien wie jetzt leger und und
und und cinque stelle die dann
ihrerseits wieder die
handlungsunfähigkeit europas verstärken
und damit den zustand noch mal
verstärken den sie selbst beklagen
also über den zweiten teil der sendung
genau auf diesen aspekt noch mal kommen
aber vielleicht können sie in einer
anderen frage auch noch aufklärung
schaffen
die regierung in rom sagt ja der
haushalt wird in zukunft wieder in rom
gemacht und nicht in brüssel
wie ist da eigentlich die rechtslage
welches souveränität haben denn die
mitglieder des euroraums der eurozone
noch über das haushaltsrecht das ist ja
ein genuines parlament sich in der
demokratie noch selbst zu bestimmen
sie haben die souveränität darüber aber
sie haben ein schöner souveränität auch
mal die europäischen vereinbarungen
ratifiziert das war ist er kommt ja
nicht aus brüssel in brüssel wird nichts
entschieden was nicht die regierungen
der mitgliedsstaaten das europäische
parlament und bei vertragsfragen auch
die nationalen parlamente entschieden
haben so und und natürlich haben die
italiener auch der ort das italienische
parlament hat mal zugestimmt dass es
sich mit seiner haushaltspolitik an
bestimmte vereinbarung halten
wird so und dieses und dieses
versprechen bricht das italienische
parlament
der bus sollte welche probleme bringen
den italien dazu dieses versprechen
jetzt zu brechen was jetzt gerade die
regierung in rom
scheinbar zwingt so eine massive
neuverschuldung anzugehen
also die argumentation der regierung ist
ganz klar also wir brauchen um aus
diesem teufelskreis in dem wir seit seit
anbeginn der finanzkrise sind also ins
in diesen zehn jahren ist unser tipp um
fünf prozent weniger gesenkt gesunken
also der das dokument produkten produkte
inlandsprodukt ja das heißt italien hat
die finanzkrise gar nicht überholt also
wir haben uns gar nicht überholt aus der
krise und das argument der regierung ist
wir brauchen wachstum wir brauchen
investitionen und um investitionen und
wachstum anzukurbeln braucht man geld
und in den augen auch eigentlich von
vielen experten es ist nicht so sehr
wieso 24 prozent defizit da was nur
durch ein drittel zwei drittel mehr als
das vorher gesehene ist es ist nicht so
sehr das problem sondern wie das geld
verwendet wird wo das geschäft gesteckt
wird und manche ökonomen sagen
eigentlich das sind sowohl taten das
sind keine richtige investitionen die
wirklich die wirtschaft ankurbeln
manche sagen es ist sogar aus deutscher
seite sind ökonom gewesen die einfach
sagen 2,4 prozent ist ja viel zu wenig
eigentlich das land bräuchte viel mehr
investitionen oder so schon eher mehr
also ein größeres wenn ich jetzt auf
diesen beiden weil sie sagen dass man
wohltaten gewesen es gibt ja
wahlversprechen ich glaube jetzt mal
zwei raus ein grundeinkommen für alle
aber oder für arbeitslose bzw abende
menschen besonders in süditalien von 780
euro pro monat und eine rentenreform mit
einer zum teil erheblichen senkung des
rentenalters begründung dann wird ein
arbeitsplätze für junge menschen frei
werden in italien gibt es eine
gravierende jugendarbeitslosigkeit im
ganzen land gerechnet 15 bis 20 prozent
in süditalien
50 prozent der staat hat ja auch in der
soziale verpflichtungen gegenüber seinen
bürgern machte sinn eine solche
investition dann in diese wohltaten in
anführungszeichen zu machen
es ist keine investition eine
investition heißt das waren
infrastruktur schafft oder sowas sondern
das ist konsumtive verwendung von
mitteln man kann natürlich die
betroffenen die arbeitslos sind
finanzieren und dann sind sie etwas
glücklicher als im moment
man kann also politische stabilisierung
durch solche geschenke erreichen aber
man kann ein land nicht wettbewerbsfähig
machen und das ist das hauptproblem von
italien und deswegen funktioniert eben
auch diese kenianischen nachfragepolitik
mit schuldenmachen nicht das ist eine
politik die ab und zu mal richtig ist
wenn ein land wirklich in den seilen
hängt weil alle leute pessimistische
erwartungen haben und die konjunktur
nicht anspringt italien hat aber kein
konjunktur problem sondern es ist zu
teuer geworden und zwar liegt das an dem
euro der euro hat italien ganz niedrige
zinsen gebracht dann hat man sich
verschuldet und hat dadurch es
ermöglicht die löhne und die preise
steigen zu lassen immer weiter immer
weiter bis die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
kaputt war
also wenn ich mal in das jahr 1995
zurück ging als auf dem gipfel von
madrid der euro dann wirklich
beschlossen wurde und zwei jahre später
kam er dann ja auch mit festen
wechselkursen für die vorstufe von da an
bis jetzt ist italien gegenüber
deutschland um genau 38 prozent teurer
geworden
und das ist so als hätten sie noch die
lehrer und hätten die und 30 prozent
aufgewertet kein land überlebt das da
ist es kein wunder dass die italienische
industrieproduktion heute noch zehn
jahre nach lehman um 17 prozent unter
dem niveau von vor dem man ist ja das
ist die reinste katastrophe den leuten
hat man gesagt ja wir machen jetzt
reformen es wird besser dann haben sie
geglaubt aber sie glauben überhaupt
niemandem mehr keinem monti mehr keinem
letter keinem renzi diese leute haben
immer nur geredet wenig reformen
und jetzt wollen sie unbedingt eine
änderung sie sind es leid sie glauben
das nicht mehr
und das ist dass man da dieser neuen
regierung das ist auch gefährlich für
europa weil die ausland zu gehen und auf
krawall aus sind geradezu die wissen
doch was sie jetzt gemacht haben wir
wissen ja dass sie die eu heizen damit
sie wollen sie reizen um den eklat
herbeizuführen um dann irgendwas zu
machen entweder kriegen sie eine
transfer-union mit ganz viel geld von
den anderen ländern oder sie wollen
austreten und dieser austritts plan den
hat paulus anwohner der ja nicht herrn
minister werden durfte und jetzt
kulturminister ist aber der starke mann
auch in dieser regierung und auch der
gute wirklich gute ökonomen den hat er
ja entwickelt obwohl man ja nach ein
großteil wir haben ja gerade gehörte
italiener eben nicht aus dem euro raus
allerdings die zahl möchte ich
bestreiten ich habe gerade eine ganz
neue umfrage gekriegt wonach 43 prozent
der italiener nur noch im euro bleiben
wollen werden 51 prozent der briten
die frage ist also wie künstlerin selbst
wenn die insel am ende der gesamten
europäischen skala italiener an die
europäische politik machen ob sie es
dann aus dem euro rauszugehen nochmal zu
diesen posten ist eine andere frage ob
sie haben den plan und bewohner hat dem
plan schriftlich jetzt gesagt haben ist
das salvini und und die macho die mario
das ja auch angekündigt haben sie sitzt
jetzt ein wahlversprechen um nochmal in
italien armut ist da ja noch sehr
gravierend im süden es gibt auch
übrigens keine funktionierende
arbeitslose arbeitslosen versicherung
wie wir sie kennen
weil die nicht gezwungen so etwas jetzt
umzusetzen
lassen sie mich noch mal den anderen
punkt zuerst aufgreifen die frage der
rente
man sollte doch auch noch mal ganz
deutlich sagen dass frühverrentung keine
neuen arbeitsplatz vor keine freien
arbeitsplätze schafft im gegenteil wir
wissen inzwischen es ist besser wenn die
leute länger arbeiten weil sie nämlich
höhere nachfrage haben und dadurch sogar
eher jobs schaffen als wenn sie früh in
die rente gehen das ist inzwischen
vielfach ausprobieren worden und das hat
sich heutzutage erledigt mit
frühverrentung schafft man nicht
sozusagen einen freien neuen
arbeitsplatz für jeden die man früher in
die rente schicken dass es mitnichten so
was sie aber tatsächlich ansprechen ist
es eben eine andere frage und das ist
ein südeuropäisches problem es gibt
keine universellen ab sicherungssysteme
wie wir sie in deutschland kennen und
das muss sich ändern in der tat das ist
ein riesenproblem dass das im prinzip
häufiges arbeitslosen versicherung gibt
diese sechs monate oder ein jahr laufen
dann ist alles vorbei dann gibt es
nichts mehr danach eine universelle
absicherung danach zu schaffen
darüber muss man sich gedanken machen
aber das kann nicht ein grundeinkommen
sein sondern es muss schon etwas anderes
sein was nach wie vor den anreiz schafft
so wie wir das in der schwedischen
hartz-reform gesehen haben als anreiz
schafft für den arbeitsmarkt zur
verfügung steht der vorwurf schwingt er
da immer mit die italienische die
italiener würden sozusagen die segnungen
des euroraums und als einen vorteil
akzeptieren aber die pflichten umgang 1
gegen die damit einher gehen also zum
beispiel die stabilitätskriterien
einzuhalten ja ich muss aber ein paar
und zwar sowohl ist nicht kulturminister
stimmt er hat früher gegen also für
austritt aus dem euro aber seit monaten
seitdem alle an der regierung beteiligt
sind inklusive premierminister und die
maya und soll jene die sagen wir wollen
dabei bleiben also gut man kann denen
nicht auch nicht glauben aber ich
irgendwie ich meine müsste man schon
eine offizielle aussage glauben schenken
also das heißt die offizielle position
der italienischen regierung jetzt wir
bleiben drin
wir haben wir unsere politik richtet
sich nicht dass da raus aus dem euro und
aus der europäischen union auszutreten
erstens zweitens also das mit der
grundsicherung stimmt also viele
experten sagen es ist ein quatsch also
manchmal gibt einfach geld um die leute
damit sie da auf dem sofa popcorn essen
und so das war von benzin die aussage
popcorn essen vor der glotze
andererseits von anderer seite ist mit
hartz4 verglichen worden also an eine
grundsicherung die allerdings einiges
höher ist als dies in höhe aber es gibt
natürlich viele viele
wieso sagen viele regelungen das heißt
kriegt man eine hat man eine andere
einkommensquelle dann wird die die summe
gesenkt und jetzt redet man anstatt drei
jahre nur 18 monate also eine minimale
justierung wird auf alle drei ebenen
übrigens herr weinmann arbeitet schon
auf einer irgend ein kompromiss mit
brüssel
es muss ja kommen also die haben jetzt
drei also knapp drei wochen zeit
ich möchte aber ein thema vielleicht
einführen und zwar die die lesenacht wie
das ganze zu interpretieren ist ist
natürlich in angesichts der europäischen
waren zuzusehen was im europäischen
parlament mainz ist klar dass wahlkampf
eigentlich diese alle beteiligten in
italien der regierung die die sind in
einem permanenten wahlkampfmodus gewesen
und geblieben
und was man da sagt ist das natürlich
dieser ganze dieser konflikt mit europa
natürlich sehr hohe einen sehr hohen
konsens einbringt und das waren sie
natürlich ausnutzen das wäre eigentlich
das kalkül und dann gibt es keinen
kompromiss
naja also man es gibt verschiedene grund
dafür ist dass bei den cologne liegt
weiter treibt der complus könnte zum
beispiel sein so so lese ich dass die
die zeitspanne von diesen drei maßnahmen
die diagnose im haushalt die würde waren
verdünnen das heißt anstatt gleich ab
januars könnte zum beispiel frühjahr
sein dass sie in kraft treten und
abmildern zum beispiel die die rente so
die die die rente kürzen und die könnte
man
auch justieren und so das könnte so ein
kompromiss sein dass man brüssel ein
sozusagen ein bonus
aber wenn jetzt nicht jetzt italien im
permanenten wahlkampf befindet ihr auch
in bezug auf die jeweils zum
europäischen parlament wie kann man das
verhindern dass die wasser das wasser
auf die mühlen der populisten geleitet
wird wie sollte sich die uhr verhalten
sollte sie versuchen ihre
maximalforderungen schuldenabbau zuerst
durchzusetzen oder kompromisse schmieden
und welche kompromisse wären das dann
richtig
damit verlor ich mag diese formulierung
nicht
italien hat sich zu etwas verpflichtet
als es dem euro beigetreten das ist
nicht brüssel oder die eu die
irgendetwas von italien verlangt das
sind die partner italien das ist
portugal das ist griechenland das ist
auch deutschland auch holland auch
finnland und all die anderen
euro-staaten aber die alle haben das mal
unterschrieben aber kompromissbereit
aber so getan als würden sie nur die
eine seite kriegen nämlich die schöne
und nicht die pflichten die damit
verbunden das menschlich
selbstverständlich aber so geht es nicht
und die gefahr ist doch also ich glaube
nicht dass die die jetzige regierung den
kompromiss anstrebt weil in der tat ich
sehe das wie sie die wollen damit
wahlkampf machen dafür brauchen sie den
konflikt mit der eu und mit den
institutionen der eu und das würden sie
bis mai treiber aber ob die finanzmärkte
das mitmachen ob die nicht die zinsen
für italienische anleihen so hoch setzt
weil also würde ich denn im moment dem
italienischen staat geld leihen und
teufel würde ich tun
ich kann noch gar nicht mehr damit
rechnen weil bei einem kurs der der
darauf angelegt ist das land gegen die
wand zu fahren dass ich mein geld wieder
kriege dann nutzen wir die schönsten
zinsen nicht sind wenn der anlagebetrag
weg ist wer sind denn am längeren hebel
in diesem fall im zweifelsfall die
finanzmärkte aber will ich eine
lebensversicherung hätte die in italien
geld angelegt hätte dann würde ich dir
aber was was pfeifen denn die
finanzmärkte sind wir alle sind wir alle
das ist nicht sind nicht irgendwelche
wilden spekulanten oder sowas und es
geht erstmal darum dass das das ist ein
das grundproblem der eu wir haben uns
schleichend
gewöhnt dass in den elitären dass das
was mal vereinbart wurde nicht mehr gilt
und damit sind aber die vereinbarung
insgesamt wertlos geworden und leider
hat die kommission ihren anteil daran
weil sie weil sie unter dem behauptung
wir sind eine politische kommission
plötzlich nicht mehr darauf achtete dass
die verträge eingehalten werden sondern
dass der willkür überließ aber aber wir
haben da eine ganz schwierige situation
und dazu kommt auch dass man sich
ehrlich macht diesen der der punkt den
herr professor sinn vorhin gesagt hätte
die steigerung der löhne in italien und
auch in den anderen krisenländern
das ist wirklich ein schlüsselpunkt die
das sind italien gehört zu den ländern
die lange inflation einfach gewöhnt
waren eine eine lohnerhöhung unter sechs
prozent war einfach keine und man hat
sich aber nach der einführung des euro
so verhalten als könne man noch wie
früher
ab werten wenn man dann zu hoch gegangen
ist bei tarifverhandlungen
das kann man aber nicht mehr wenn sie
ihre und wenn sie ihren wechselkurs
nicht mehr ändern können und sind in
schwierigkeiten
dann können sie nur noch sich selbst
erinnern was verdammt schwer
es gibt keine alternative dazu
oder diese einsicht lief an der fehlt es
in ja aber das sind ja das ist das
resümee ihre äußerung ist aber ja
eigentlich dass man die kuh gar nicht
vom eis kriegt nur diese populistische
regierung in italien aus form eines
pensionisten könnte eine langwierige
angelegenheit werden
das ganze muss zwischen kurz und lassen
sie sich ganz dem gedanken es gibt es
gibt für italien und für andere südliche
länder die auch zu teuer geworden sind
in der blase vor lehmann die durch die
teure verursacht wurde vier
möglichkeiten erstens wir machen eine
transferunion und finanzieren die
fehlende wettbewerbsfähigkeit dauerhaft
mit mitteln aus dem norden
das wird sehr teuer dass wir wollen auch
viele ich das zementiert auch die
situation dann wird der wird ganz
südeuropa zum italienischen mezzogiorno
zweite möglichkeit die preise die zu
hoch sind gehen wieder runter geht aber
kaum sie können ein land kaum in die
deflation drücken das ist nicht immer
therapie da gehen viele
da geht die gesellschaft kaputt dritte
möglichkeit denn der norden deutschland
und andere länder werden nach
inflationiert im süden ist zu teuer
jetzt folgt der norden nach das können
wir den sparer nicht so wirklich antun
und die und die vierte möglichkeit ist
austritt und abwertung das was schäuble
wollte mit griechenland so das ist eine
fürchterliche situation keine dieser
lösung kann man irgendwie empfehlen es
ist eine sackgasse in die europa hinein
gekommen ist und dass mit den schulden
und so weiter vorüber und jetzt
diskutiert es ist ja nur ein äußeres
geplänkel an der oberfläche des
geschehens irgendwie manifestiert sich
jetzt der streit dann streitet man sich
über dieses oder jenes aber das
fundamentale problem kriegt man damit
nicht weg und aber keine lösung ist ja
auch keine lösung was muss jetzt
eigentlich passieren aus dieser
situation heraus in der jetzt italien
und damit ja die europäische union
zumindestens die länder die im euroraum
sind stecken
ich denke kurzfristig wird es wirklich
darum gehen dass die europäische union
hier sehr standfest bleibt im interesse
des weiter als europäischen union im
interesse daran dass nicht noch mal so
etwas wie in griechenland passiert dass
man plötzlich den großen rettungsschirm
aufspannen musste er diesmal viel größer
werden müsste aber auch um ein wenig
glaubwürdigkeit zurückzugewinnen aber
was ich glaube was langfristig sein muss
ist erstes das von europäischer seite
von seiten brüssels tatsächlich man sich
ehrlich macht in eine ganz andere
richtung hat ein versprechen gegeben was
man ganz offensichtlich nicht einhalten
kann nämlich dass sich die länder
wirtschaftlich annähern und der
wohlstand in europa sich an er das ist
tatsächlich in der gegebenen strukturen
nicht möglich und ich glaube das wird
ganz wichtig sein um auch wieder
zustimmung zu gewinnen
dass diese tatsache anerkannt wird dass
man nicht mit mit struktur von mittel
die man von nord nach süd und von west
nach ost umgeschichtet diese anpassung
hinbekommt das ist letztlich de facto
das ist selten gelang ist irland wo der
krise hat sich von einem armen land mit
der struktur hilfen der eu zu einer
enormen wirtschaft sagt irland sollte
man immer ganz besondern nehmen weil da
haben wir
noch ein steuerproblem vielleicht kommen
wir dann aber dass ich danach mache ich
glaube was eben auch sehr wichtig ist
was ja auch ein schleichender prozess
ist und das ist für mich zu den vier
punkten von herrn sinn noch ein
wichtiger fünfter punkt wir reden ja
dauernd von strukturreformen aber man
jeder versteht etwas anderes darunter
ich denke was ganz wichtig ist dass man
eben sieht das ist ein schleichenden
prozess gibt von süd nach nord der
innovationsgetriebenen menschen der
innovationsgetriebenen firmen und das
zementiert diese offene schere zwischen
nord und süd ost wird sie weiterhin auf
machen wir sehen dass wir im
gesamteuropäischen markt sozusagen ihn
nutzen können und uns nur noch fragen
müssen wenn wir ein unternehmen haben wo
ist in der beste standort wo sind die
besten standortbedingungen und die sind
nun mal nicht in italien gerichten weiß
überreguliert ist weil es schlecht
durchsetzung von gesetzen hat was
schlechte steuern hat und vieles weitere
mehr und diese struktur reformen so
lange die nicht angegangen werden wer
wenn nicht sehen dass es eine gewisse
außerdem gleichheit der
lebensverhältnisse in europa da gibt es
ja ideen da gibt es die fiskalunion
da gibt es die vergemeinschaftung von
schulden da gibt es eine banken union da
gibt es auch die forderung das
steuersystem zu vereinheitlichen die
sozialversicherungen zu vereinheitlichen
das würde ja diesen möglicherweise diese
gleichheit schaffen macht das einen sinn
in diese richtung europa
weiterzuentwickeln denn das wäre ja eine
sehr starke integration europäischer
strukturen zum teil ich glaube eben dass
die unternehmerische entscheidung anders
fallen da schaue ich mir an wie lange
brauche ich dann um einen anspruch
durchzusetzen wenn ich in italien
griechenland fünf oder zehn jahre
braucht dann gehe ich da gar nicht erst
hin
oder wenn ich in innovationsgetriebene
ist unternehmen gründe oder ist schon
habe und sehe dass ich 30 prozent meiner
zeit mit bürokratie verbringen muss dann
gehe ich damit wir sehen es doch sowohl
was die italienischen innovativen
unternehmen dieses jahr aufweise gibt
wie auch andere sie gehen weg aus
italien und ganz schleichend dass das
feld gar nicht so richtig auf aber wenn
man eben über die lange zeit hin schaut
der fotos die mannschaft
den früheren italienischen regierung
schon gemacht hat die hätten ihre
hausaufgaben nicht gemacht
diese strukturreform nicht durchgeführt
bürokratieabbau und und und gibt es denn
da jetzt anzeichen dass man daraus
gelernt hat und dass die regierung wie
auch immer sie jetzt vorgeht da auch das
machen wir wirklich in der tat unter
unsere achillesferse dass wir auf diesen
schuldenberg sitzen und egal was wir tun
wird dass uns richtigerweise auch
angekreidet das ist das größte problem
die regierung offiziell sagt dass im
rahmen dieser dieser dieses
haushaltsgesetz oder entwurf auch
vorgesehen ist dass man die schulden
bekämpft also dass diesen schuldenberg
niedriger setzen möchte möchte aber ein
thema also angeschlossen was kollege
oder gesagt hat und zwar was man ständig
bei uns liest ist das eigentlich der der
der ur fehler dieser ganzen konstruktion
ist wie der euro zustande gekommen ist
also wir haben jetzt eine situation
wurde euro für deutschland günstig ist
billig ist und die exporte einfach in
die in die höhe
hingehen und für uns also für viele
südländische länder europäischer länder
ist einfach zu teuer
dh wir kommen aus diesem teufelskreis
nicht raus und ich finde egal ob man
diese regierung verteidigen möchte und
das ist wirklich nicht meine rolle aber
es ist schon einen anspruch jedes
einzelnen landes einfach das eigene wohl
zu bedenken einfach sagen wir müssen da
raus wir müssen sondern die also arbeit
schaffen wir müssen einfach armut
bekämpfen und ein fehler natürlich
dieser regierung ist dass wir da riesige
widersprüche sehen weil das ist nicht an
sich die gewählte regierung aus der wahl
ist eigentlich keine eindeutige kein
eindeutiges mandat herausgekommen es ist
ein kompromiss zwischen eigentlich zwei
gegenseitige kräfte das heißt wir sehen
ein bisschen mit dem bürgerforum ein
bisschen links wir sehen mit der
freitags ein bisschen mitte rechts und
so das ist natürlich ein novum in europa
und ich glaube das tut europa richtig
angst andererseits die die petition in
italien ist nicht nur die also das sage
ich wirklich nur als bürger das
richtigerweise andere länder in europa
oder die kommission einfach sagen schau
mal da hast du wirklich falsche
hausaufgaben gemacht aber eigentlich es
ist ein kampf sozusagen um die regierung
zu stürzen das ist was man subjektive
oder seiner so emotional empfindet es
geht nicht nur um einhaltung der regeln
es geht um was anders um die angst dass
die durch das ist ja das erste land wo
eine populistische regierung sozusagen
an der macht ist dass das reichen und
machen
wir haben also man redet
der linkspopulistische die ehrung in
griechenland zieht wir reden in europa
aneinander vorbei es fahren jetzt hier
zwei züge aufeinander ungebremst die
europäische union und italien
herr krause wie kann diese gilt es jetzt
mal fehlkonstruktion euro in ihrer
entstehungsphase wie sie jetzt auch sich
in der praxis zeigt wie kann das
korrigiert werden oder kann das gar
nicht korrigiert werden
das wird sehr schwer
ich würde mal sagen damit für italien
nicht ganz so hin und vor der krise 2009
10 waren zwei norditalienische regionen
die lombardei und noch eine andere weil
ich in venetien wahrscheinlich waren die
reichsten region in europa in der eu das
vermögen der privaten haushalte in
italien ist im schnitt höher als das
deutschland nur da hat man jetzt um mehr
hinzuweisen dass das potenzial ist
italien norditalien hat zum teil
fantastische industrien in der
möbelindustrie design und aber nicht nur
dass maschinen etc
das heißt sie müssen sich schon auf sich
selbst besinnen aber natürlich wir haben
in vereinbarung gemacht in europa und
und die müssen gelten und wir können
jetzt also ich habe zugehört klar für
deutschland ist der euro viel zu niedrig
bewertet wie italien ist als zu hoch
bewertet
dann muss man sagen dann muss man
rausgehen es ganz schwieriger prozess
es hat immer spaß gemacht aber sie
können doch nicht erwarten dass dann tun
sich dann die erfolgreich
wirtschaftenden nation sich nach denen
richten die nun wirklich mit ihrem
zuhause die struktur reformen die wir
eine italien gibt es gesetze die das
unternehmertum behindern bis zum
abwinken wenn sie hat sich daran
versucht hat leider nicht sehr viel
geschafft aber das ist ja das was mit
strukturen und das unter das
mittelständische unternehmen manchmal
gar nicht wachsen wollen weil sie dann
in eine größenordnung geraten wo das
arbeitsrecht anders wird und und und und
unter kunde da kann italien selbst viel
machen aber dass man kann nur nicht
sagen ich lebe auf
auf kosten anderer und es gab eine das
ist die die die inflationsrate in
italien die löhne sind in einer weise
gestiegen die in allen südlichen
krisenstaaten die die länder einfach
nicht verkraftet auch der euroraum quasi
schon wieder eine währungsreform
also es wird offen für die in italien
dieses thema das wissen sie auch
diskutiert und zwar hat die regierung
das jetzt nicht mehr in ihrem programm
stehen aber das erste programm das dann
zurückgezogen wurde dieser jetzigen
regierung enthielt ja den vorschlag eine
parallelwährung einzuführen
die sonder mini bots staatspapiere die
fein gestückelt sind und auf papier
gedruckt sind das so aussieht wie
geldscheine mit dem man bezahlen kann
und dann wollte man den weg den
möglichen weg aus dem euro heraus
definieren und paulus einwohner von dem
wir schon sprachen hat ja auch gesagt ja
also was man machen muss ist man darf
das ja nicht zu geben sondern man muss
es bis zur letzten sekunde strikt leute
dass man das vorhat und dann muss man es
machen
ich sage nicht dass sie es wirklich
machen wollen nur die situation und ich
habe viel verständnis für die italiener
ist verzweifelt bei dieser hohen
jugendarbeitslosigkeit bei dem wachstum
dass nicht kommen will die leute sind
verzweifelt wir können doch nicht sagen
wir machen einfach so weiter und wir
zwingen nur die italiener irgendwelche
schulden kriterien einzuhalten das
seitlich lösung das ist nicht die lösung
es muss etwas grundlegendes passieren
und entweder ist das grundlegende des
italien sich zu einer deflation
durchringt dass deutschland sich durch
ring zu einer inflation
oder man macht den austritt wie paulus
anwohner das an die wand gemalt hat der
ist doch nicht dumm das war auch der
chef von confindustria vom
industrieverband das ist ein gewiefter
ökonom der bolivianische dem
nobelpreisträger studiert hat der weiß
genau was er tut und man ist mit dem
rücken zur wand und ist nicht mehr
bereit diese sprüche zu hören sondern
man will was grundlegendes machen
was es sein kann müssen die italiener
ganz alleine entscheiden ich hoffe dass
sie drinbleiben ich hoffe nicht dass sie
rausgehen aber wenn sie rausgehen muss
man auch das verstehen wenn sie es tun
da wird die welt nicht zusammenbrechen
weil sowie der euro jetzt funktioniert
mit der fehlenden wettbewerbsfähigkeit
und der masse ihren
jugendarbeitslosigkeit im süden kann es
doch nicht weiter geld
diese beginnen die zinserhöhung auf den
nationalen märkten auch im euroraum ist
noch nicht eingetreten soll aber kommen
wäre das eine möglichkeit die italiener
von größten dummheiten abzuhalten weil
ja dann ist uns selbst gesetzt scheinen
für die irischen staatsanleihen
insgesamt die zinserhöhungen dass man
davon ablässt weil man diesen schulden
irgendwann gar nicht mehr bedienen kann
dass ich fürchte wenn man die jetzige
regierung das machen ließen würden sie
es einfach durchziehen weil sie nicht in
die mittlere frist schauen das ist nicht
ihr interesse interesse ist eindeutig
ein anderes insofern glaube ich nicht
dass das problem einfach durch die
märkte von alleine gelöst wenn die
europäische union sollte macht man das
glaube ich nicht
aber lassen sie mich noch einen anderen
punkt machen der eigentlich in meiner
aus meiner sicht noch mal sehr wichtig
ist man muss ja noch mal zurück sehen
sie hat mir das vorhin gesagt kurz vor
einführung des euros gab es eine phase
in der all die länder die diesen
beitrittskriterien sich verpflichtet
haben tatsächlich einen echten anreiz
hatten reformen echte strukturreformen
durchzuführen
und wenn man sich diese phase ansieht
dann ist es im prinzip die einzige phase
in der alle südeuropäischen ländern sich
sehr positiv entwickelt haben
einfach weil sie durch diesen hohen
anreiz in den euro einzutreten zu können
und diese kriterien erfüllen zu müssen
plus zusätzliche auflagen eben für
reformen diese auch ernsthaft damals
angegangen sind
was wir da und danach ist im prinzip
vergessen waren zu sagen was müssen wir
denn jetzt innerhalb der eurozone
aufrechterhalten um diesen reformprozess
fortzusetzen was danach passiert ist es
so dass man viele der reformen zurück
gedreht hat auch das ist eine ursache
dafür warum
verschiedene länder in südeuropa dann
wieder runter gegeißelt wenn wir nach
spanien und portugal sehen läuft es
jetzt eigentlich nach den letzten
reformen gar nicht so schlecht
was es aus meiner sicht aber heißt ist
tatsächlich muss man wenn man die
eurozone in irgend einer form mit neuem
leben beleben will ist ein großes
projekt schaffen mit einem eben solchen
anreiz versetzen das tatsächlich in
diesen ländern wieder der reformprozess
zum laufen das wird jetzt kein guter
zeitpunkt seien aber man muss sich
nachher zukunft darüber gedanken machen
ob es nicht ein solches projekt gibt was
neue anreize für diese länder die den
realistischen wir damals auch
realistisch dass aber ich wage zu
bezweifeln ist es damals
ich meine wie italien portugal spanien
haben 1995 zwölf prozent zinsen zahlen
müssen auf die staatspapiere deutschland
nur 7 das waren fünf prozentpunkte mehr
und dann als der euro dann angekündigt
wurde fielen auf einmal innerhalb von
zweieinhalb jahren diese zinsen auf das
deutsche niveau
italien hat fünf prozent zinsen gespart
das ist gewaltig sie hätten ihre
mehrwertsteuer streichen können und
hätten immer noch ein plus gehabt und
stadt jetzt dieses geld zu verwenden um
die schulden zurückzuzahlen hätten sie
das gemacht da werden sie heute unter 60
prozent schuldenquote haben sie es
lieber verfrühstückt das ist die
wahrheit und das hat natürlich einen
kenianischen nachfrage seitigen buch
erzeugt der zu einer blase wurde die
radikal wäre nicht so schlimm wie ihn
noch in anderen ländern aber jedenfalls
führte das zu dieser hyperinflation fast
mit den starken lohnsteigerungen die
heute des problems darf ich in den
letzten verbleibenden nochmal auf die
bündchen konsequenzen dieses streits
eingehen sollte wie weit ist in die
italienische regierung bereit diesen
streit auf die spitze zu treiben da gibt
es ja jetzt schon drohungen richtung
brüssel wenn ihr das nicht akzeptiert
was wir euch jetzt vorgelegen haben dann
überlegen wir uns ob wir zum beispiel
die sanktionen gegen russland verlängern
wollen das war ja der ministerpräsident
gestern in moskau gewesen
er hat so ein bisschen anderen cipra
sich ein vorbild genommen der das auch
schon gemacht nach dem motto wenn ihr
nicht wollt hole ich meinen schlagen
großen bruder hat mich sehr viel
gebracht was
das ist immer schwierig als sehr wichtig
halte ist die erklärung von von noch
finanzminister trier der gestern in
einer talkshow gesagt hat wenn es so
weitergeht mit dem mit dem mit dem also
wie nennt man das die aufschläge
wir haben das jetzt 320 wenn es so
weitergeht das als limit wird 400
gezählt also gesehen wenn es so weiter
gehen das schaffen wir nicht also ewig
kann das land mit nicht mithalten
das heißt ein bisschen vielleicht kommt
doch die die die therapie von den
märkten und was die premierminister und
die zwei vize ist einfach sagen ist
einfach kein keine rückweisung von dem
gesetz also von diesem haushaltsgesetz
aber gesprächsbereitschaft das heißt es
muss wahrscheinlich bist also als auch
als datum wird weihnachten an angepeilt
also das bis dahin wird nichts passieren
also es wird wahrscheinlich in diesen
drei wochen innerhalb also
innerhalb dieser drei wochen wo man
einfach mit brust verhandeln muss oder
eine antwort geben muss da muss irgend
einer eine gesichtswahrung weiter sei es
schon eine idee wie sie sein könnte ja
also man machen was man nicht was habe
ich vorhin gesagt dass man das verdient
diese ganzen maßnahmen sie werden
einfach hinter eintreten was man sagt
okay wir sind euch entgegen gekommen ihr
uns und so und dann wird man sehen
natürlich die spielen auf zeit weil im
mai sind eben die europawahl und wichtig
ist wir servieren und die mario dass sie
einfach die wirklich die die
zusammensetzung des parlaments im
industries burg einfach auf menschen wir
haben uns jetzt 41 nun etwa über dieses
thema unterhalten und alles aufgezählt
was nicht geht
die frage was geht ist sehr viel
schwieriger zur beantwortung lösung auch
wenn man das jetzt mal auf die ganz
obere ebene hebt herr krause europa soll
ja eine wertegemeinschaft sei man tut
sich zusammen aus den erfahrungen des
zweiten weltkriegs und der insgesamt der
europäischen vergangenheit
der soll indikation stattfinden da
sollen sich alle wohlfühlen da sohnes
wohlstand geben
das soll das wachstum das eine zukunft
geben wenn man das jetzt mal als
europäische idee insgesamt tituliert
breiten wir da gerade ein totes pferd
es ist noch nicht tot aber wissen in
europa wird nicht mit einem großen knall
schalter sondern europa wird ganz
allmählich scheitern das wird erodieren
zerbröseln und ich glaube dass dieser
prozess schon angefangen hat der ist
nicht unaufhaltbar aber wenn man nichts
tut wenn man so weitermacht wie bisher
dass man immer wieder gnade vor recht
ergehen lässt dass man immer wieder
immer mehr akzeptiert dass länder die
urteile des europäischen gerichtshofs
nicht akzeptieren dass sie sich nicht an
die völlig korrekt zustande gekommenen
entscheidungen der eu ministerrat halten
etz rätseln wir sozusagen aufgeben dass
das gemeinsame recht denn das ist das
was die eu ausmacht dann wird das so
weitergehen also der point of no return
überschritten
ich glaube nicht dass es in der politik
einen point of no return gibt aber der
wie wir wir haben das zugelassen mit
großzügigkeit mit manchmal sagen jahre
da muss man geduld haben und und und und
das ist dann immer mehr das hat man mit
milchquoten angefangen die italien über
es auch mal nicht eingehalten hat lange
her und hat damals berlusconi bei
anderen einstimmigen entscheidungen die
eu erpresst und sagt entweder
legalisiert ihr das nachträglich oder
ich blockiere hier alle entscheidung
das war in den 90er jahren und das ist
sogar so ganz allmählich harmlos
angefangen und inzwischen sind wir bei
der währung bei einem sehr ernsten thema
und die frage ist ob die politik das
überhaupt in der hand behalten kann
eine viel größere sorge ist dass italien
von den finanzmärkten daran erinnert
werden wird was passiert und und und
wenn dann diese zins abstände dieses
genannte maß von über vier prozent
erhöhen
das wird sich nachher potenzieren das
wird ist wie im hinspiel schnee weil der
den an grund läuft und und und das ist
das was einem sorge nach muss
diese finanzmärkte erinnern ja nicht
italien daran sondern auch die
europäische union bleibt italien in
europa als europäische nation
ich denke schon und zur zur sicherung
der deutschen kollegen würde ich einfach
sagen dass ressourcen weist es bestimmt
also italien eigentlich gründet auf sehr
soliden basis ja also was verschuldung
ist es ist alles fast in italienischen
händlern die die immobilien also
italiener also und im vergleich also im
gegensatz zu deutschland wir sind nie in
der folgt gegangen und wir haben immer
unsere schulden zurückbezahlt sie sagen
von einer starken basismetallen ist die
drittgrößte volkswirtschaft im euro-raum
wir sind jetzt leider am ende der
sendung wir werden das aber ganz
bestimmt weiter beobachten mit
fortsetzung auch mit ihnen vielen dank
das sind arbeiten die zuschauer bleiben
sie dafür nichts
[Musik]